aujourd'hui on va parler de révolution à
part une révolution pour la maison pour
l'intérieur avec une solution qui va
combiner les nouvelles technologies de
la data de la donne est connecté votre
foyer comment est ce qu'on arrive à
combiner tout ça pour vous faire
économiser de l'argent ce mode facture
d'électricité je vous parle aujourd'hui
d'une solution qui est super
intéressante c'est une vidéo qui réalisé
en partenariat avec mary barry est venu
me chercher en nous on tient monsieur
gros si tu pouvais vous présenter notre
solution si tu pouvais montrer comment
on fonctionne quelle est la révolution
derrière marie c'est vrai quand on me
l'a proposé au début ça a soulevé
beaucoup de questions je vais changer de
fournisseur d'électricité je vais
essayer de nouvelles solutions mais
quand il s'agit de changer dans mon
foyer directement toujours un petit peu
mitigé là j'ai essayé j'ai changé les
switch et je suis passé chez barry et je
vais vous dire ce que j'en pense
[Musique]
je ne suis pas encore inscrit je vais
faire je vais regarder avec vous il faut
rentrer mon numéro de téléphone
ensuite j'ai toutes les inscriptions
affaires prénom email enfin j'ai rentré
l'information mon point de livraison
j'ai rentré mon numéro de téléphone
ajoute de l'argent at-on soldes baril à
l'avance nous prélevons directement se
soldent il sera recharge automatiquement
ou payer la conso du moi j'ai la
possibilité de pré payées mais je
préfère payer au moins comme ça je paye
au réel et ça ça me conviendrait très
bien donc la séance à toutes les
informations de souscription ribes et
compagnie nous nous occupons du
changement de fournisseur une fois que
nous aurons le feu vert pour te font
naître et cités nous te ferons savoir
ici donc voilà donc là j'ai plus qu'à
attendre maintenant
et puis ensuite je re toutes les
informations alors je vois que j'ai déjà
les petites infos là ma conso paiement
parrainage module je vais pouvoir suivre
tous directement ici depuis
l'application ça ça m'intéresse donc je
vous fais un ptit clap qui va durer pour
vous quelques secondes et pour moi ça va
durer quelques semaines le temps de
découvrir le service de barry pour vous
donner mon retour tranquillement
d'ici quelques semaines valorise la
première chose que j'ai fait quand on a
parlé de bari c'est d'aller voir sur
leur site internet qu'ils étaient ce
qu'il faisait on voit ce verre on voit
ce blanc on voit perdre la formation
nous parle de données on nous parle de
datar nous parle de plein de choses
ok ça c'est bien mais en réalité qui est
baril donc allez cliquer ici en haut qui
sommes nous et là en cherchant et en
descendant on trouve sa réponse on voit
que marie est l'entreprise la plus jeune
de la famille fortum fortum fortwo qui
est un groupe énergétique finlandais
kalle en 1932 et on voit qu'elle a été
fondée au danemark en 2018 les basée à
copenhague et qu'elle vient tout juste
d'arriver en france
en 2021 l'entreprise toute nouvelle qui
se lancent et qui propose une solution
qui est vraiment innovante et une autre
façon de voir l'énergie est le mieux
pour vous expliquer ça c'est regarder
l'application l'application elle se
trouve ici barry titi comme anvers
cliquer dessus
la première chose qu'on va revoir on
arrive de sucer les informations sur le
marché c'est à dire que vous avez des
informations sur le prix l'électricité
en temps réel vous voyez combien coûte
le kilowattheure actuellement vous avez
des infos sur les énergies renouvelables
les informations sur votre consommation
moi ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est de
venir voir ce que j'ai réellement
consommé depuis que j'ai souscrit un
abonnement
donc là je vais vraiment ce que j'ai
consommé heure par heure ici c'est les
kilowattheures je peux vous dire pour le
coup la nuit concentre un peu moins 0,03
centimes d'euros entre 1h et 2h du matin
et forcément la journée ça va augmenter
un peu en fonction de ce que je vais
venir en faire est-ce que je rejette
beaucoup de co2 dans l'atmosphère ou pas
tout est ici mon taux d'énergie
renouvelable ça m'a coûté plus cher ici
entre ces deux êtres 10 heures et midi
l'après midi je suis relativement
tranquille et je vois que ça augmente le
soir je vois que en termes de co2 et
bien forcément ces corps et les jeux les
forcément rejeter plus de co2 au monde
consomment le plus
mais par contre là j'ai un max
d'énergies renouvelables moment où j'ai
consommé entre 10h du matin jusqu'au
soir alors sa baisse un petit peu après
le soir mais par contre tout l'après
midi là j'ai beaucoup d'énergie
renouvelable mais joie par contre que ça
m'a réellement coûté jour par jour alors
j'ai des jours un peu plus élevé à 2
euros 17 g des jours un petit peu moins
à 1 euro disent vraiment la fluctuation
là par exemple le mardi le mercredi 7
avril société à 96 centimes ce qui est
vraiment important et ce qui m'intéresse
réellement c'est de devenir acteur de la
consommation électrique grâce à ce que
vont pouvoir récupérer sur mon compteur
linky oui ce n'était pas de la magie il
vous faut un compteur linky et les dix
qui s'occupe du réseau va récupérer les
informations et à les transmettre à bari
alors aujourd'hui il récupère toutes les
24 heures si par contre de miley disent
les transferts en temps réel marisa
capable de les récupérer en temps réel
pour vous ayez la date a justement heure
par heure en temps réel alors tout ce
qui va être informations sur le réseau
vous les avez vous les connaissez vous
savez donc à quel moment vous avez de
l'énergie verte ça c'est vraiment super
parce que y'a un geste citoyen n'a rien
à se dire ok moi je vais venir à ce
moment-là utiliser l'électricité parce
que c'est l'électricité verte et que je
veux justement utiliser quelque chose
qui est vert qui est green
d'ailleurs on des verts derrière vous
l'avez vu donc ça s'inscrit vraiment
dans un choix citoyen mais on n'est pas
ennemis nous brûlent nos intérêts ce qui
fait vous allez pouvoir dire également
consommé lorsque prix est beaucoup plus
bas imaginez par exemple vous avez une
voiture électrique vous avez une borne
et vouloir charger chez vous c'est un
exemple est super super intéressant et
bien vous devez recharger votre voiture
lorsque l'énergie et la moins chère ce
qui fait que vous allez payer beaucoup
moins cher la recharge de votre voiture
il existe différentes solutions et c'est
justement là où barry intéressante parce
qu'ils ont ouvert une api donc
différentes applications externes
pourront venir se connecter recharger
votre voiture au moment où l'énergie
sera la moins chère imaginez un ballon
d'eau chaude connectés qui pourrait
chauffer l'eau quand l'énergie sera la
moins chère donc il ya beaucoup d' usage
pour la bo qui sont super intéressant
tout ça n'existe pas encore il faut
venir codé barry fournit les outils et
tout ça va pouvoir venir ce piloter et
elle est de plus en plus loin dans les
temps à venir grâce à la pays avec cette
solution ont fini les heures pleines
finies les heures creuses fini les
estimations de consommation fini les
factures de régularisations alors
jacques le le point un peu négatif de
tout ça c'est que en hiver si vous avez
par exemple un chauffage électrique
et bien vous allez vous retrouver que
des factures beaucoup plus élevé que
l'été fatalement vous allez consommer
davantage
là où d'autres solutions permettront de
venir à l'iss et à l'année avec une
régularisation en fin d'année à votre
avantage ou pas ici il y aura pas de
régularisation et s'il n'y aura pas de
lissage vous allez payer plus
l'hiver par rapport à ce que vous allez
consommer et vous allez payer moins
l'était bien évidemment sur un chauffage
électrique mais ce qui est intéressant
derrière si vous allez voir venir vous
pilotez et choisir comment vous allez
venir chauffer à quelle heure pour vous
n'est pas vraiment optimisé payer au
réel sans mauvaises surprises et en plus
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est que
barid vous facture l'énergie qu'on prix
coûtant au prix auquel il achète donc
ils gagnent pas d'argent sur l'énergie
qu'il vous facture ils gagnent de
l'argent sur les abonnements payants
l'abonnement de base commence à 11 euros
0,4 par mois bien évidemment vous
paierez un peu plus cher votre
abonnement si vous avez besoin de plus
de puissance mais sinon le prix de
l'énergie est totalement transparent ce
que je retiens dans cette expérience et
ce qui m'intéresse avec marie c'est
qu'effectivement je suis pas tous les
jours sur mon application à regarder tu
as un coût de tels prix tiens je suis
sûre de l'énergie verte là je suis pas
sur l'énergie verte
je suis pas tout le temps dessus une
faute extrêmement transparent toute la
journée on a plein de choses à faire là
je vais bosser la géci à faire donc je
suis pas tout le temps dessus quand j'ai
besoin d'allumer j'allume voyez là par
exemple ici et je suis en train de
filmer j'ai donc de l'énergie ici qui
est en train de se consommer j'ai aussi
des éclairages daria bon c'est de la
lède à ça consomme pas beaucoup mais
j'ai pas tout le temps le nez dessus
ce que je trouve super intéressant c'est
que vous achetez votre énergie à prix
coûtant donc ça c'est un gros point
positif si vous souhaitez si vous êtes
vraiment engagés dans cette démarche là
vous voyez réellement sur votre
application
à quel moment vous allez avoir de
l'énergie renouvelable vous allez voir
également comment vous allez acheter le
moins cher mais peut-être la grosse clé
du succès est le réel intérêt plus plus
plus plus plus de bari c'est leur api
c'est le fait vous allez pouvoir
connecter votre maison alors c'est en
train de se mettre en place est en train
de se développer
mais voyez notamment ce qu'on peut faire
avec une voiture électrique à la maison
vous la recharger moment où l'énergie
est la moins chère ça c'est vraiment
super intéressant d'autant plus que la
recharge la nuit c'est souvent la nuit
que c'est moins cher
donc ça c'est tout bénef et on peut
réfléchir plus loin on peut aller par
extension je vous le dis sur une
chaudière connecter sur un ballon d'eau
chaude
on peut venir tout optimisé comme ça
grâce à cette api et ça pour moi c'est
un très grand plus d'ailleurs je vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
essayé mari vous pouvez partir à tout
moment ça vous plaît pas il n'y a pas de
ni de frais de résiliation tout se gère
depuis votre smartphone dans votre
application
d'ailleurs je vous ai mis un code de
parrainage juste ici vous pouvez leur
entrée lorsque vous vous inscrivez ça
vous permettra d'obtenir 30 euros
d'électricité gratuite
et ça c'est vachement bien à vous nous
dire ce que vous en pensez vous comment
vous trouvé cette idée effectivement de
récupérer d'adata grâce à votre compteur
linky afin de pouvoir tout piloté vous
dans votre application de consommer
moins cher de consommer plus intelligent
de pouvoir optimiser de consommer aussi
plus vers moi je veux ça cool moi ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas aux
commentaires sur ce je vous embrasse on
va beaucoup d'amour et à très bientôt
ciao